[Musica]
datti una possibilità amate non è una
frase che ho iniziato ripetermi davanti
allo specchio per caricarmi no è una
frase che susanna la persona per me è
molto importante
mi ha detto all'inizio di questo
percorso che ho intrapreso ormai due
anni fa
me l'ha pure scritto su una bandiera una
bandiera che ha cucito mia madre che
costruisco quindi oggi gelosamente in un
cassetto e la possibilità me la sono
data però non a me stesso l'ho data di
una visione e non l'ho fatto
assolutamente da solo ma l'ho fatto
proprio con la partecipazione di tante
persone che in questi due anni hanno non
so come deciso di camminare come verso
la stessa destinazione
è questa chi vi racconto oggi proprio
l'inizio la storia del nostro primo
capitolo come sono andate le cose allora
faccio un passo indietro andiamo 2009
mila euro in economia alla bocconi a
milano e subito danaro reato mi capita
proprio palma così questa opportunità
l'opportunità di lavorare per per quella
che era la mia azienda di moda del cuore
avevo questa sorta di amore
adolescenziale per questo brand che in
quel momento stava iniziando il proprio
piano di espansione globale e cercava
dei managers da formare mi offrono neo
laureato il periodo di training a londra
un contratto a tempo determinato
trasferimento a milano e poi possibilità
di carriera tutto fantastico se non
fosse che in realtà fu già la valigia in
mano perché stavo per andare a
barcellona ero stato infatti preso di un
master in università molto importante in
europa e avevo già pagato la prima rata
universitaria e bloccato l'appartamento
guarda mio padre le dico fota penso che
il master possa aspettare magari poi
tornò a studiare furono due anni non
preoccuparti però quell'aereo quel
giorno l'ho preso per londra
il master non l'ho più fatto e iniziata
così proprio la mia carriera nel mondo
della moda avevo 23 anni mi trovo fin da
subito catapultato in un mondo che dire
travolgente poco perché inizio di aprire
stores uffici in tutta europa diventa
uno dei proprio di porta bandiere di
questo brand che che scatenava una
reazione euforica nelle persone a
livello globale che che è difficile
scrivevi la passione con cui viveva ogni
giornata
ed effettivamente poi le possibilità di
carriera arrivano perché nel 2012
diventò signor manager in germania e nel
2013 un ruolo importante con
ministratore per il diversi tiri incluso
un caso che era un organo un team
globale proprio destinato con la
funzione di favorire l'integrazione dei
dipendenti internamente ma soprattutto
favorire quali integrazione del brand in
tutti quei paesi nei quali gradualmente
stavano piantando le nostre bandiere
in questo ruolo
inizia così un percorso diverso inizia a
scoprire che in realtà il dietro le
quinte del fashion since globale era un
po diverso da quello che avevo vissuto
fino a quel giorno mi rendo conto che
che non era così tutto felice e nasce in
me proprio un senso di malessere che
viene amplificato da un fatto tragico
accaduto proprio quell'anno il crollo
della plaza in bangladesh rana plaza
brevemente era un complesso di edifici
molto grande che ospitava diverse
fabbriche tessili che produce un appunto
abbigliamento per per una trentina di
brani famosissimi sono sicuro che tutti
voi in platea se se aprite oggi il
vostro a maggio avete almeno una
maglietta e un paio pantaloni che sono
usciti da lì
ecco gli edifici che il 24 aprile del
2013 purtroppo sono crollati e hanno
ucciso 1.138 persone e ferite gravemente
più di 2500 non si è trattato di un
incidente questa è la cosa più tragica
si è trattato di una tragedia
assolutamente evitabile i palazzi già
mostravano segni di cedimento tant'è che
i lavoratori stessi ne avevano
denunciato i responsabili e lo stato di
avanzato pericolo però il responsabile
per un'altra opportunità prima fra tutte
continuare a produrre era impensabile a
smettere di produrre quando c'erano
queste richieste sempre più pressanti da
parte delle case di moda occidentale sia
in termini di pricing e in termini di
tempistiche però purtroppo quel giorno
quella scelta è costata la vita a
migliaia e migliaia di persona
mio padre si trovava in bangladesh
quando è crollato rana piazza e il
ricordo di averlo chiamato è il pensiero
che ho fatto allora lo stesso che
custodisco g che rivolgo anche a voi
ma quand'è che il prezzo dei vestiti che
andiamo ad acquistare è diventato più
importante della vita delle persone che
riproducono e aspen
no
in genere
[Musica]
alessio moto
è difficile rimanere impassibili quando
si vede questo quando sono usciti questi
filmati nel 2015
io lavoravo già nel mondo della moda da
ormai sei anni e mezzo ma come cavolo è
possibile che abbia contribuito a creare
tutto questo schifo senza assolutamente
rendermene conto era completamente
ignaro di tutto ciò quel senso di
malessere che avevo iniziato a
sviluppare nel 2013
diventa sempre più più forte e diventa
anche molto difficile nasconderlo
a un certo punto la realtà oggettiva e
questa la moda diventata oggi la seconda
industria più inquinante al mondo dopo
quella petrolifera consuma una quantità
di risorse naturali e umane ad un tasso
esorbitante e quindi misto guardate lo
specchio visto e letto ma matteo cavolo
se non ci provi tu se non si provi tu a
cambiare le cose oggi che sei
consapevole che altro ma può farlo
meglio se non ci proviamo noi tutti
assieme a ridisegnare un futuro migliore
di quello che ci si prospetta chi altro
mai può farlo la realtà che siamo nati
cresciuti in un sistema noi già
disegnato da altri ma questo sistema è
ovvio che non funziona più bisognava
tracciare linee nuove tracciare una
visione completamente diversa e
percorrere prendere un nuovo binario e
quindi la domanda che che proprio mi mi
pongono a fine ma materno quand'è che
c'è stata l'ultima volta una vera e
propria rivoluzione ban questa ragazze
di casa va tantissimo
cioè non riuscivo a dormire la notte più
pensavo a queste cose tante le domande
tante le risposte che iniziò a scrivere
butterei giù che diventano in qualche
modo il seme di un business plan per cui
la fine ha preso dall'euforia pam
sconvolgo tutti deciso di licenziarmi
lascio mio ufficio a monaco lascio la
mia carriera il mio posto fisso e
ritorno ritorno qua a casa vicenza per
far cosa la rivoluzione
ecco
se prima non dormivo la notte perché era
animato da tutti questi pensieri se
volete anche un po romantici ora il
problema era un altro non dormiva notte
perché ve lo chiedo anche a voi ma ma
come cavolo si fa la rivoluzione c'è
adesso mi trovo in questa questa
situazione che che diventa anche
difficile in qualche modo giustificare
gli altri cosa stavo andando a fare è
l'unica cosa l'unica certezza che avevo
era la mia visione la visione di creare
un movimento con con dei ragazzi che in
qualche modo delle persone che fossero
animate come me dalla consapevolezza che
ciò che indossiamo non ci rappresenta
più del punto di vista valoriale ed era
necessario lavorare assieme per perché
era un modo una moda un modo di essere
completamente diverso innovativo capace
soprattutto di rispettare le risorse
naturali ed umane che stanno dietro ciò
che indossiamo al fine di garantire vita
per le generazioni future
non un progettino da poco da solo non
l'avrei mai fatta per cui mi rendo conto
che ha bisogno dei compagni di viaggio e
li trovo le persone a me più vicine
victor che mio pilastro la mia vita da
tanti anni e federica federica amica
d'infanzia anche la impegnatissima sul
fronte ambientale e sociale con diverse
organizzazioni con loro scrivo proprio
il primo atto di questo percorso
decidiamo di fare un viaggio un viaggio
in giro per l'europa con uno scopo ben
preciso quello di andare a piantare il
seme della consapevolezza in tante città
diverse
con la speranza che in qualche modo
parlando con delle persone queste si
animassero come noi andassero poi fare
delle cose funzionali ad attivare il
cambiamento positivo per la moda ed
effettivamente succede questo
partendo in questo viaggio la cosa
straordinaria che quella che era
inizialmente la la mia visione realtà
era già diventata nostra perché da dal
solo ero passato tre persone è tornato
poi a vicenza dopo due mesi e mezzo
siamo partiti a barcellona siamo andati
abbia rit san sebastien fino al nord
europa e poi giù di nuovo in italia
avevamo creato qualche modo movimento
l'attrarre vamo diventati 5 10 15 20 500
400 nasce broad nasce questa community
che che inizialmente appunto rode il
nome che diamo alla nostra pagina
instagram per comunicare e veicolare le
nostre avventure ma immediatamente ci
rendiamo conto che diventa qualcosa di
più diventa l'aggettivo scelto dalle
persone che spontaneamente iniziano a
dire io sono road perché perché perché
anche loro animate da questa voglia di
diventare il re consueta causa proprio
dei rivoluzionari come noi
tante le voci che si avvicinano in
questo senso silvia una delle voci più
importanti all'interno del movimento
anche lei la incontro prima del viaggio
la ripesco dopo e si avvicinano di ci
voglia investire tutta me stessa per
catalizzare questo cambiamento lavorare
con voi e dopo si arrivano alvise matteo
mia sorella anna alberto santiago è
sceso un tante le voci che
contribuiscono a trasformare questa voce
in un vero e proprio ruggito un ruggito
che portiamo dentro le scuole perché tra
il 2015 e il 2016 a questo punto
decidiamo di collaborare con le scuole
per andare a ballare ragazze di queste
cose partendo da un liceo poco distante
da qui il liceo classico antonio
pigafetta realizzava un progetto
educativo che pensate oggi disponibile
92 paesi nel mondo
abbiamo tracciato la nostra strada
andando a a piantare il seme della
consapevolezza eravamo riusciti in
qualche modo gradualmente e lo stiamo
facendo tuttora ad alimentare questa
voglia di cambiamento funzionale e poi
allora all'inizio del 2016 per portare
rod ad uno stadio di sviluppo successivo
perché dall'ispirazione ad un certo
punto diventa veramente impellente
cercare di passare ai fatti
e questa voglia di cambiamento diventa
contagiosa e avvicina a noi tante realtà
industriali di diverso tipo che iniziano
a darci a disposizione i mezzi per
portare sul mercato non tanto dei beni
dei prodotti da gestire ma dei beni che
fossero originali accessibili innovativi
sostenibili ma allo stesso tempo reale
riflesso del nostro manifesto
tantissime le storie che che nel 2016
attiviamo in questo senso però una fra
tutte ve la voglio raccontare perché è
particolarmente curiosa e simpatica
è una storia legata all'economia
circolare la moda consuma tessuti
sostanze chimiche energia acqua in
quantità spropositate per cui
dan da mesi ci interrogavamo su su come
cercare di realizzare qualcosa che fosse
funzionale ad amplificare questo
messaggio e parlare di questo problema
di una massa di persone più la più ampia
e allo stesso tempo capace poi invece di
risolvere effettivamente qualche modo il
sistema è l'opportunità ne arriva quando
susanna la stessa delle bandiere di cui
ho parlato all'inizio viene da me un
anno e mezzo dopo mi fa matteo ion
svariate tonnellate di polveri di
grafite di scarto di perché susana le
abbia un'altra storia ma lui non so se
col turn e c'è possibilità di di
applicarla c'era la possibilità di
riutilizzo nel nella moda nel fashion
io non lo sapevo giro la domanda silvia
esperta di finiture silvia
effettivamente scopre che duemila anni
fa i romani già attingevano con la
grafite
oggi la grafite viene buttata via la
cosa straordinaria è che scopriamo anche
che questa pratica non era finita in
epoca romana ma delle donne di un paese
a noi diventato creare molto caro
monterosso calabro e avevano tramandata
di generazione in generazione fino ai
giorni nostri
loro nelle uniche depositarie di questa
conoscenza c'era solo una cosa da fare a
questo punto ci riprendiamo i nostri
zaini del viaggio dell'anno prima e
partiamo andiamo monterosso calabro per
scoprire come si fingevano grafite le
matrici inconscio livello manduca
guidati da stephen once upon a time in
china
munster di dead rising talking fascismo
[Musica]
monterosso calabro e sauro il dito
confederations junior action cui di
stare più impianto istante qui upcycling
i leicester tigers
senta più tech a scappare in order to
montfort nasce così facendo un passo
indietro nella storia graf haiti graf e
chi è stato il primo nostro vero props
pro dato un prodotto con un obiettivo
che nasce proprio per raccontare la
storia di forme alternative di tintura
che in qualche modo in questo caso fanno
economia circolare perché partivamo
dalla grafica di scarto ma allo stesso
tempo diventa negli ultimi mesi il mezzo
attraverso il quale siamo riusciti a
finanziare un programma di ricerca
sviluppo che ha portato a questa forma
di tempur ad uno stadio di innovazione
successivo tutte le persone che hanno
sanno deciso di vestirsi di graf haiti
hanno infatti supportato la questa
quella ricerca per arrivare al deposito
di un brevetto per una forma di tintura
ancora più innovativa per un tessuto che
altamente inquinante il denim quello che
abbiamo tutti addosso quando restiamo
con dei pantaloni di jeans e questa
forma di tintura è straordinaria perché
ci consente di ridurre proprio l'impatto
ambientale in termini di consumo d'acqua
sostanze chimiche ed energetico del
tessuto dell 85 per cento
eccolo 85 per cento da solo come dato
forse non vi dice niente basta che vi
dica che un singolo paio di jeans può
arrivare a consumare fino a 9.000 litri
d'acqua e ci rendiamo conto proprio
della novità che che che porta questa
che ha portato graf haiti non soltanto a
noi ma per industria intera
ecco una novità che è scaturita da una
situazione di crisi ed è questa la cosa
importante la qualche mese farà ad una
conferenza è una persona che mi ha
ispirato parlava delle tre grandi crisi
che ci troviamo a fronteggiare oggi c'è
una crisi spirituale siamo sempre alla
ricerca di nuove ideologie
c'è una crisi sociale ed umanitaria c'è
una crisi ambientale
io sono convinto che nella loro
drammaticità queste crisi in realtà solo
la nostra più grande chance il progresso
siano veramente la nostra opportunità di
ridisegnare nuovi modelli di business
capace di riportare la persona e il
pianeta al centro di tutto e non più un
consumatore avido di consumare prodotti
in quantità sempre maggiore questo è
fatto questo è il futuro per me il
futuro ha fatto di consapevolezza
il fatto di partecipazione se la parte
di chi produce che la parte di chi
consuma quando noi indossiamo ai vestiti
non indossiamo soltanto degli oggetti
indossiamo veramente la storia delle
persone che li hanno fatti e la storia
della natura che li ha portati sul
mercato possiamo continuare a scegliere
di vestirci in modo irresponsabile
oppure possiamo scegliere di vestirci un
qualcosa che ci rappresenti nello
spirito uno spirito che noi chiamiamo
prot
uno spirito che trova il proprio il
proprio entusiasmo nella realizzazione
che il cambiamento sia veramente
possibile possiamo realizzarlo noi tutti
assieme
grazie al vostro coinvolgimento grazie
alla scelta di tutte le persone che da
domani possono decidere di indossare non
più dei vestiti ma degli oggetti che in
qualche modo abbiano una coscienza una
prospettiva ci consentono di guardare il
mondo senza vergogna senza alcun senso
di colpa ce la vogliamo dare questa
possibilità assieme
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]